alors nous commençons donc notre journée
en accueillant les représentants des
entreprises de réseaux sociaux que je
remercie de leur présence dans cette
table ronde donc nous avons mesdames
beatries sevrard et Élisa Boury estrade
qui porteront la parole de méta monsieur
Éric Garandeau celle de TikTok et enfin
Madame Sarah bouchaoua portera la parole
de snapchat
Mesdames et Messieurs un questionnaire
vous a préalablement été adressé par
notre rapporteur donc je vous laisserai
le soin évidemment de nous le
transmettre rempli par par la suite je
précise que l'ensemble des membres de la
commission d'enquête a été destinataire
ce matin des réponses qui ont été
apportées par la société Twitter dont la
représentante n'a pas pu être présente
avec nous cet après-midi les
informations correspondantes peuvent
donc naturellement figurer dans nos
débats et en tout cas contribueront
aussi à la la prise en compte par le
rapport si la commission d'enquête vous
a convié à prendre part à cette table
ronde c'est que nous nous penchons sur
les événements violents en marge des
manifestations du printemps dernier nous
nous attachons adresser le
portrait-robot des auteurs de violence
et à caractériser leur mode opératoire
mais aussi à examiner l'encadrement de
ces rassemblements par les autorités
publiques pour pointer ce qui a bien
fonctionné et ce qui potentiellement
peut aussi être améliorée vous
comprendrez donc que les entreprises de
réseaux sociaux nous intéressent
doublement d'abord parce qu'en amont des
violences elle constitue un des canaux
d'organisation des groupuscules qui
évidemment peuvent chercher à faire
circuler des informations via les
réseaux sociaux ensuite car en aval les
données et les vidéos qui ont transité
par
vos plateformes peuvent être employées
par les autorités aussi bien
administratives que judiciaires pour
identifier les fauteurs de troubles
alors avant de vous faire prêter serment
il me revient d'ouvrir les débats je le
ferai en vous soumettant les deux
premières questions qui permettront à
chaque plateforme de ce positionner en
premier lieu en amont des violences
relevez-vous des pratiques particulières
permettant à des utilisateurs de
planifier des actions violentes selon
des modalités propres à chacune de vos
plateformes si vous en êtes informé et
si vous jugez le contenu dangereux
procédez vous un signalement à
l'autorité publique ou prenez-vous
éventuellement des décisions de gestion
de contenu de l'application et en second
lieu après la Commission des violences
cette fois quelle est la nature de vos
relations avec l'autorité publique et
tout notamment l'objet de réquisition
dans le cadre d'enquête judiciaire et
comment y donner vos droits alors
Mesdames et Messieurs avant de donner la
parole et en application de l'article 6
de l'ordonnance numéro 58 1100 du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
de nos assemblées parlementaires je vais
vous demander de prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité et donc ce que je vous propose de
faire on va commencer par Madame Evrard
puis madame Bourrier estrade puis
monsieur Garandeau et ensuite madame
bouchaoua donc
simplement à tour de rôle si vous pouvez
effectivement brancher votre micro levez
la main droite et dire je le jure
vous en remercie
alors attendez on va
on va recommencer pour Madame Bourrier
stade
merci beaucoup je le jure je vous en
remercie
beaucoup et donc sans tarder je vais
vous passer la parole donc et puis
ensuite évidemment je passerai aussi la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur pour que
celui-ci puisse poser ces questions et
puis enfin je passerai aussi la parole
aux membres de la commission qui
souhaiteront la prendre dans le dans le
prolongement donc je ne sais pas qui
parmi vous souhaite démarrer
il faut que vous branchez le micro
le président monsieur le rapporteur
les plateformes que vous avez réunies
aujourd'hui sont avant tout des lieux
d'expression qui offrent une voix à
chaque individu en ce qui concerne méta
plus spécifiquement afin de répondre aux
questions préliminaires que vous avez
soulevées ont souhaité donc vous
présenter comment s'applique les
standards que nous utilisons et on va
courir également donc le sujet de la
coopération avec les autorités
judiciaires et de police qui intéresse
votre commission
nos plateformes permet donc à des
communautés de se fédérer autour
d'intérêt et de passion mais sont aussi
largement utilisés dans les milieux
notamment militants et associatifs en
démocratisant l'accès au débat public
qui est devenu gratuit et accessible en
un clic ces dernières années plusieurs
mouvements d'ampleur sont nés ou ont
émergé grâce aux réseaux sociaux je
pense bien sûr à MiTo mais également au
printemps arabe
cette expression est rendue possible par
des outils qui sont universels se sont
en effet et c'est important de le dire
les mêmes partout dans le monde mis à
part le fait que nous testons des
fonctionnalités dans quelques pays avant
de les déployer dans le monde entier il
n'y a pas de spécificité nationale des
produits de méta
pour autant cette liberté d'expression
essentielle en ce qui nous concerne
n'est pas sans limite tout d'abord le
droit s'applique il convient de rappeler
que les plateformes et le numérique en
général constituent aujourd'hui un
secteur hautement régulé en France et en
Europe sur les 10 dernières années pas
moins de 29 textes ont introduit ou
réguler des technologies numériques de
sécurité on va dire de géolocalisation
de reconnaissance faciale etc
au niveau européen le rgpd a posé un
cadre devenu la référence internationale
en matière de protection des données
personnelles et plus d'une quinzaine de
textes sont soit déjà en application
soit très prochainement le seront je
pense notamment bien sûr au RSN la
régulation est donc riche et fournie
mais nous n'avons pas attendu cette
régulation pour agir depuis sa création
méta a élaboré des règles strictes
définissant ce qui peut ou non être
publié sur ces plateformes elle
répondait un principe simple qu'on
trouve dans la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme et du Citoyen 2789 la liberté
consiste à pouvoir faire tout ce qui ne
nuit pas à autrui à titre d'exemple nos
standards interdisent plusieurs types de
contenus pertinents pour les travaux de
cette commission tout d'abord les
contenus violents mais aussi
l'incitation à la violence et donc pour
prévenir des dommages potentiels hors
ligne nous supprimons les propos qui
incitent à la violence ou qui la
facilite
nous supprimons également des contenus
désactivant des comptes et cooperons
avec les forces de l'ordre lorsque nous
estimons qu'il existe un risque réel de
dommages physiques ou de menaces
directes pour la sécurité des individus
nous interdisons aussi aux internautes
de faciliter d'organiser de promouvoir
ou d'admettre certaines activités
criminelles ou préjudiciables visant des
personnes des biens des entreprises ou
encore des animaux
nous autorisons les internautes à
débattre et à défendre la légalité des
activités criminelles et préjudiciables
ainsi qu'à attirer l'attention sur les
activités dont ils peuvent être témoins
ou victimes tant qu'il ne coordonne pas
les dommages et qu'il ne les mettent pas
en avant qu'il n'est pas laurise pas
pour protéger les utilisateurs des
images choquantes violentes nous
supprimons les contenus particulièrement
violents donc ça va être des choses
comme des vidéos de démembrement des
corps de personnes décédées ça conduit
très violent dans le cadre des
discussions sur des questions
importantes telles que les violations
des droits de l'homme les conflits armés
ou les actes de terrorisme nous
autorisons le contenu graphique avec
certaines restrictions pour permettre
aux utilisateurs d'en parler de
condamner et afin de sensibiliser à
certaines situations
nous ajoutons un panneau d'avertissement
sur certaines images afin que les gens
sachent qu'elles peuvent être sensibles
avant de cliquer dessus
ces politiques et bien d'autres encore
nous les faisons appliquer grâce à une
combinaison de moyens humains et
technologiques plus de 40 000 personnes
travaillent aujourd'hui aux enjeux de
sécurité et de sûreté chez méta donc
près de 15000 modérateurs et sur les
cinq dernières années nous avons investi
plus de 16 milliards de dollars dans le
domaine de la sécurité c'est plus que
n'importe quelle plateforme à la fois en
volume absolu mais aussi relativement à
leur taille grâce à nos outils
automatisés nous détectons et retirons
des millions de contenus par jour dans
le monde et pour en rendre compte nous
publions chaque trimestre un rapport de
transparence qui inclut des éléments sur
le nombre de contenus retirés les appels
déposés par les Utilisateurs ou encore
le taux de prévalence de ces contenus
sur lequel on pourra revenir
en vous rendant sur le site
transparentif.fb.com dont nous vous
enverrons le lien bien entendu vous
pouvez par exemple constater que nous
avons retiré 13,6 millions de contenus
violents sur facebook donc 98,3% avaient
été détecté proactivement c'est à dire
avant signalement de toute utilisateur
dans le monde entre janvier et mars 2023
sur la même période nous avons retiré
plus de 7 millions de contenus incitant
à la violence sur Instagram dans plus de
97,5% avaient été détecté avant tout
signalement ces outils et ses standards
sont en évolution permanente et je vais
laisser Béatrice revenir sur quelques
exemples récents de ces de ces de ces
évolutions
bonjour Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur effectivement on
voulait faire un petit point particulier
sur les outils que nous déployons pour
justement soit faciliter la vie des
utilisateurs mais aussi vous expliquer
comment on pouvait mesurer tous les
chiffres qu'on vous donne il faut savoir
que par exemple notre
notre rapport de transparence et audité
par un tiers certificateur qui en fait
vient vérifier la méthodologie utilisée
je voudrais revenir juste sur un élément
qui est le taux de prévalence dont Elisa
vient de parler qui nous aident en fait
à mesurer l'impact des violations sur
nos plateformes ce taux revient un petit
peu à mesurer le taux de concentration
des polluants dans l'air c'est en fait
une mesure qui indique le pourcentage ou
le nombre de fois un contenu nocif peut
être vu par nos utilisateurs j'insiste
sur le côté vu car ce que nous mesurons
ici c'est bien la viralité et non la
quantité en fait des contenus où on
considère qu'en fait le danger est
beaucoup plus important à partir du
moment où le contenu est bien évidemment
vu par nos utilisateurs
nous avons effectivement
eu des statistiques enfin les
statistiques vous les trouverez sur le
rapport de transparence sur les contenus
violents ou graphiques ou incitant à la
violence donc ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui le taux se situe entre 0,02%
et 0,04 %. ça veut dire que pour 10000
contenus vus de à 4 portes sur reste en
tout cas sur des contenus violents ou
incitant à la violence c'est une en fait
comme si vous mettiez une voiture
banalisée dans la rue pour un petit peu
de capter les violations qui restent sur
la plateforme pourquoi c'est important
ce type de métrique parce que ça nous
permet d'identifier si notre
intelligence artificielle et nos
modérateurs font le job correctement et
ici on arrive à capter véritablement ce
qui est dangereux pour nos utilisateurs
vous avez bien évidemment le taux de
prévalence pour toutes les catégories de
violations qui concernent nos
plateformes que ce soit sur les contenus
haineux et autres là je vous ai ressorti
uniquement ceux sur les contenus
violents
un autre point sur lequel je voudrais
insister vous le connaissez certainement
ce sont aussi comment on peut rendre
acteur nos utilisateurs les signalements
sont extrêmement puissants même si comme
l'a dit Elisa on retire majoritairement
proactivement c'est à dire avant tout
signalement des utilisateurs ces
contenus qui violent nos standards donc
la charte que vous signez quand vous
rentrez sur nos plateformes les
signalements en deux clics permettent à
tout de suite à tout un chacun de
pouvoir signaler un contenu qui serait
non conforme à nos standards ou que vous
trouviez que vous trouveriez en initiité
par rapport au droit ça permet en tout
cas pour nous c'est extrêmement
important ce sont des signaux
extrêmement importants sur lequel c'est
important de se baser et qui viennent
compléter tout le travail de
l'intelligence artificielle
l'autre outil les autres outils parce
qu'il y en a moult ça va être également
comment en tout cas gérer ce que les
utilisateurs veulent voir vous avez tout
un arsenal d'outils qui est mis à
disposition aussi des utilisateurs
permettant notamment de bloquer des
contenus ou des comptes qui ne
souhaiteraient pas voir ou alors de
masquer certains mots certains emojis
qui ne souhaitent pas recevoir donc on a
tout un panel en tout cas d'outils qui à
disposition d'utilisateur pour qu'il
soit aussi acteurs et non juste
spectateur de ce qui se passe sur la
plateforme même quand ce sont des
contenus violents
l'autre point sur lequel on voulait
insister et qui fait référence au
deuxième séquençage de votre question et
savoir sur comment on coopère avec les
autorités
on travaille avec tout un ensemble de
l'écosystème notamment des associations
sur lequel depuis bien longtemps on a
déployé des partenaires de confiance qui
sont en capacité de nous remonter des
contenus qui sera en violation de nos
standards et qu'on va traiter en
priorité ce type de dispositif le RSN ou
DSA donc c'en est largement inspiré pour
avoir repris cette mesure en tout cas
dans le texte qui aujourd'hui va être
étendue par les pouvoirs aussi de
l'arcome à titre d'exemple on travaille
par exemple avec génération numérique où
il enfance qui peuvent nous remonter des
signalements on a bien évidemment
également les forces de l'ordre avec
lesquelles nous coopérons notamment je
pense à Pharos qui est la plateforme
pour tout ce qui est signalement de
contenu illicite sur Internet qui
comprend notamment les contenus violents
avec lequel nous travaillons depuis
maintenant des années pour vous donner
un ordre d'idée nous traitons et c'est
une donnée qui est publique et
réellement dans également dans le
rapport de transparence nous traitons
plus de 25000 requêtes uniquement pour
la France chaque année donc ça c'est
vraiment uniquement le chiffre français
où tous les ans nous traitons ce type de
demande pour les forces de l'ordre de
françaises avec un taux de conformité
qui est supérieur à 85%, ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que quand on nous
demande ces informations si on ne les
trouve pas parce que le compte a été
supprimé ou parce que l'adresse IP ne
vient pas taper en France ou parce que
tout simplement l'adresse donnée n'est
pas correcte ça tombe effectivement dans
les pourcentages sur lequel on ne va pas
pouvoir donner ce type d'information
nous avons une équipe dédiée avec une
personne francophone qui est en lien
étroit avec les autorités pour pouvoir
justement fluidifier
et travailler avec les autorités
publiques nous faisons également partie
du groupe de contacts permanents qui
avaient été mis en place par Bernard
Cazeneuve à l'époque des 2015 ou 16 j'ai
un trou mais je crois que c'est 16
justement suite aux attentats de
terroristes qui a eu en France mais sur
lequel on a pu aussi travailler plus
largement sur la manière dont les
requêtes étaient envoyées auprès des
plateformes enfin et pour anticiper
peut-être toute question que vous
pourriez avoir sur les émeutres récentes
et donc la manière dont nous avons
traité ces
cet événement nous avons bien évidemment
mobilisé nos équipes dès le début pour
répondre rapidement aux quelques
demandes que nous avons reçues nous
avons bien évidemment rappeler les
procédures lors de notre entretien avec
le ministère de l'Intérieur et du
numérique sur ce sujet et nous n'avons
pas en tout cas dans le cas de cette
procédure mis en oeuvre eu de points de
blocage particulier
on s'arrête là pour la
le prélier les questions après il y a
aucun aucun problème on reste à votre
disposition très bien merci beaucoup
Adam oui ça permettra évidemment aux
autres plateformes aussi de s'exprimer
TikTok d'une part et puis snapchat
d'autres parts peut-être passer la
parole à Monsieur guérandeau Merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur Monsieur et Madame député
peut-être quelques mots pour présenter
la plateforme Tik Tok c'est une
plateforme où l'on vient avant tout
regarder des contenus des contenus qui
sont des vidéos courtes de format
vertical donc c'est avant tout un média
sur lequel on vient s'informer se
divertir c'est un média communautaire
donc ce sont aussi des utilisateurs qui
vont poster des contenus donc c'est
plutôt une plateforme vraiment de voilà
de de création et de et de diffusion
avec un toute une série de contenus qui
reflète évidemment toutes les toutes les
passions individuelles et collectives
mais je dis aussi je présente un peu
c'est de la plateforme de cette façon
parce qu'on s'éloigne un petit peu des
d'un réseau social au sens strict du
terme c'est à dire que les
fonctionnalités qui permettent
d'interagir entre des individus sont
assez limités puisque le but c'est avant
tout de créer des vidéos et de les
partager et donc ces vidéos vont être vu
évidemment le but c'est qu'elles soient
vue par un plus grand nombre de
personnes donc c'est une autre façon de
dire que quand on vient
échanger les informations que l'on
souhaite garder confidentiel ou qu'on
veut partager dans un cercle restreint
qu'on a des activités
illicites ou répréhensibles c'est pas
forcément sur Tik Tok qu'on va venir
parce que c'est une plateforme qui
justement est une plateforme qui vise à
partager de manière ouverte des contenus
nous n'avons pas par exemple de
messagerie pour les moins de 16 ans pour
les moins de 18 ans la messagerie est
désactivée par défaut pour les plus de
18 ans la messagerie existe mais elle
est pour l'instant très réduite
puisqu'on ne peut pas échanger de pièces
jointes et c'est pas une messagerie
cryptée c'est pas une messagerie
éphémère
et on ne peut pas non plus constituer de
groupes de discussion donc c'est
forcément du point à points entre deux
personnes qui ont accepté d'échanger
ensemble donc voilà on se définit plus
comme une plateforme plateforme créative
plateforme où on vient regarder des
vidéos plus que comme un réseau social
cela n'empêche pas évidemment qu'on soit
très vigilant sur tous les risques qui
peuvent exister liés à la diffusion de
vidéos qui auraient des finalités
d'hommageables et c'est ainsi que tout
ce qui est vidéo violente vidéo visant à
commettre des activités violentes des
vidéos visant à nuire à autrui à nuire à
des personnes individuelles à nuire à
des groupes à nuire aussi à des biens
privés ou publics toutes ces vidéos sont
évidemment interdites par nos Conditions
générales d'utilisation par nos règles
communautaires et
ça va très loin dans le détail je vais
pas rentrer dans toutes les les
catégories mais c'est vraiment tout type
de violence tous types de vol tout type
de destruction de tous types de biens
tout ce qui est aussi fournir des
instructions sur la manière de commettre
des activités criminelles qui pourraient
nuire aux personnes bien aux animaux
aussi
tout ce qui peut considérer tout ce qui
peut être considéré comme une menace à
la vie humaine à tout ce qui peut donner
lieu à des violences à des blessures et
donc tout cela est totalement interdit
sur sur la plateforme
et donc on a évidemment outre
l'interdiction qui est fixée dans nos
règles communautaire on a une équipe de
40000 personnes au niveau international
qui est chargé de vérifier que ces
règles sont bien appliquées donc ce
qu'on appelle les forces trust and
safety dont le responsable est irlandais
est basé à Dublin et donc ces équipes
vont
accomplir un travail à la fois de
modération humaine et aussi un travail
de d'organisation des algorithmes des de
ce qu'on appelle l'apprentissage par la
machine qui va détecter de manière
proactive et de manière de plus en plus
sophistiquée toutes les formes de
violence donc ça peut être des violences
graphiques ça peut être des violences
verbales ça peut être des gestes ça peut
être des codes aussi puisqu'on sait que
certains groupes fonctionnent par en
utilisant un langage codé pour justement
échapper à la vigilance de nos machines
et de et des modérateurs
pour donner un chiffre pour ceux qui
concerne la France on a 600 modérateurs
de langue française qui interviennent
quotidiennement sur sur la plateforme
alors vous pouvez vous souhaitiez savoir
s'il y avait des
changements récents dans les pratiques
ces dernières années notamment liées à
l'activité de groupe musculaire violent
alors il est vrai que nous avons observé
notamment au printemps 2023
une augmentation des vidéos qui ont été
retirées parce qu'elles étaient
synonymes de contenu violent graphique
de contenu extrémistes violents ou aussi
de désinformation dangereuses puisque la
désinformation est aussi interdite sur
notre plateforme j'ai oublié de le dire
et par exemple sur cette période entre
le 16 mars et le 3 mai 2023 on a retiré
au total 79210 vidéo
et donc 37 776 qui violait nos
politiques par le contenu violent et
notamment la violence visuelle de ces
images
7133 vidéos qui violaient nos politiques
sur l'extrémisme violent et 8700 vidéos
qui violaient nos politiques sur la
désinformation dangereuse il est
intéressant de mentionner que 93% de ses
vidéos ont été
retirés de manière proactive et que
ce chiffre montre même à 99% sur ce qui
concerne la désinformation dangereuse
la politique qui est appliquée c'est une
politique de réponse graduée
c'est-à-dire qu'on commence par
supprimer les contenus parfois même ce
sont les simples avertissements mais dès
lors qu'il s'agit de violence on
supprime tout de suite le contenu et si
le contenu est
très dommageable ça va même être le
compte qui va être supprimé parfois dans
d'autres cas ça va être plusieurs coups
de ce nom c'est ensuite on supprime le
compte lui-même c'est-à-dire que
l'utilisateur ne pourra plus du tout
accéder à la plateforme et là par
exemple au printemps 2023 donc on a
supprimé 945 comptes au-delà de la
suppression des vidéos
on est en contact évidemment étroit avec
Pharos qui peut nous signaler des
contenus de manière c'est-à-dire de
l'administration peut nous signaler
évidemment des contenus et puis on est
aussi évidemment discussion avec les
autorités administratives judiciaires
pour des réquisitions plus formelles et
dans ces cas-là évidemment on veille à
pouvoir donner une réponse très rapide
aux demandes qui sont faites
particulièrement dans des dans des
périodes troublées on a parlé de ce qui
s'est passé au printemps on pourrait
parler aussi de ce qui s'est passé plus
récemment des émeutes entre le 27 juin
et le 3 juillet ou les demandes ont été
traités dans leur notamment ils
demandent administrative ou Jud
on publie toutes ces données alors pas
forcément de manière aussi précise mais
enfin je veux dire pas sur des périodes
aussi courtes mais tous les trimestres
nous publions ces données à travers un
rapport un rapport de transparence qui
permet d'avoir à la fois l'ensemble des
infractions qui ont été relevées les
différents chefs de qui ont conduit à
supprimer les vidéos ou les comptes et
on signale aussi on recense toutes les
sollicitations que nous recevons des
pouvoirs publics et donc on est en
contact aussi bien avec l'OCL CTIC côté
police nationale que la gendarmerie ou
le logique
voilà ce que je peux peut-être dire pour
pour une première intervention merci
beaucoup monsieur Garandeau simplement
une question pour vous demander une
précision un moment donné dans votre
exposé vous avez fait référence au fait
que il pouvait exister de la
désinformation dangereuse et que en pari
cas de figure il convenait également de
d'écarter
évidemment le message
comment comment faites-vous pour pour
identifier entre guillemets cette
désinformation dangereuse alors tout à
fait on a merci de permettre d'apporter
quelques précisions
si je prends par exemple le cas des
élections en période d'élection le fait
de pouvoir d'indiquer que la date d'une
élection n'est pas la vraie date par
exemple ou de
tout ce qui peut nuire à la à la vérité
en matière de de manière de voter tout
ce qui est permis en matière de vote que
ce soit les dates des élections des
candidats qui se qui sont déclarés tout
cela est considéré comme une
désinformation dangereuse pour nous et
donc là on va appliquer une modération
immédiate dans la mesure où ce sont des
données objectives et d'ailleurs dans
l'occurrence quand c'est le cas on a
d'ailleurs un mini site qu'on crée à
l'intérieur de Tik Tok qui recense
toutes les informations officielles et
qui vont ensuite renvoyer sur les
informations officielles du Ministère de
l'Intérieur ou du service
intergouvernemental de communication
ensuite lorsqu'il y a un doute donc là
ça peut être à l'occasion de de
manifestations par exemple ou
je parle pas des guerres ou on a
évidemment le brouillard de la guerre et
certaines personnes peuvent répandre des
informations
erronées et à ce moment-là les
modérateurs n'ont pas forcément la
connaissance du terrain dans ces cas-là
on va
[Musique]
soit sur signalement qui peut être fait
parce que nous avons aussi un bouton de
signalement qui permet à tout un chacun
ou à des associations référencées
de nous saisir et ou simplement parce
que nous-mêmes nos modérateurs ont un
doute on va saisir des vérificateurs de
fait qui sont des agences on en a plus
d'une vingtaine dans le monde on a l'AFP
notamment et donc l'AFP par exemple va
aller vérifier l'authenticité de
l'information et tant que cette vidéo
n'est pas vérifiée enfin que
l'authenticité de l'information n'est
pas vérifiée toute utilisateur qui
clique sur cette vidéo verra apparaître
un pop-up qui lui indiquera attention
cette vidéo est susceptible de contenir
de la désinformation elle est en train
d'être vérifiée donc il est bien ça en
tête êtes-vous sûr de vouloir consulter
cette vidéo si il veut vraiment la
consulter pourra le faire mais au moins
il aurait eu cette avertissement et
quand on aura le retour du vérificateur
de fait à ce moment-là la vidéo si elle
est fausse elle sera supprimée
et sinon elle sera évidemment restituée
elles sont remise en circulation
je vous remercie je vais passer la
parole à votre voisine donc à madame
bouchaoua vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
tenais tout d'abord à vous remercier
pour l'organisation de cette audition
autour d'un sujet majeur celui de la
protection de nos utilisateurs et de nos
principes démocratiques et j'espère par
mon introduction répondre à l'ensemble
des questions préalables que vous nous
avez envoyées et les trois premières
questions que vous nous avez posées en
début d'audition donc tout d'abord
snapchat est une plateforme de
communication visuelle qui a été créée
en 2011 et qui a pour objectif en fait
de reproduire nos interactions
quotidiennes entre amis et famille
conscient de cette nouvelle forme de
communication que sont les plateformes
nous avons essayé de concevoir snapchat
différemment c'est à dire que nous
pensons que les réseaux sociaux ne
doivent pas se résumer en une
compétition entre utilisateurs ou le
sensationnel et le partage massif
d'informations l'emporterait face à
l'authenticité on va dire et la
protection de notre communauté à cet
effet snapchat est une plateforme dite
fermée où l'utilisateur est dans
l'obligation de s'inscrire pour accéder
en fait à l'ensemble des fonctionnalités
qui se divisent en cinq axes majeurs la
plateforme a été conçue elle-même sur
deux principes clés et désolé pour
l'anglais 6 mais privacy et safety by
difood donc vie privée et
confidentialité par défaut nous offrons
à titre d'exemple pas de fonctionnalités
live streaming il y a pas de critères de
vanité publique avec des gemmes ou des
partages de même l'ensemble des
conversations sont privées donc je
voulais dire en préambule la plateforme
se divise en cinq fonctionnalités clés
dès qu'elles se lancent elles s'ouvre
sur une caméra qui permet d'interagir
avec des expériences en réalité
augmentée et non pas sur un fil
d'actualité gouverné par des algorithmes
de modération de recommandation pardon
opaque nous avons par la suite la
fonctionnalité phare de snapchat qui est
la messagerie interpersonnelle que nous
concevons un peu comme un espace de
confiance entre utilisateurs c'est à
dire que pour interagir avec un
utilisateur l'amitié se doit d'être
réciproque tout d'abord par la suite
toute capture d'écran ou tout
enregistrement de messages et
directement notifié à l'interlocuteur et
enfin nous avons des le groupe privé
cependant en fait ces groupes privés
sont limités en nombre et ne sont pas
publiques vous pouvez pas être plus de
100 à titre d'exemple sur un groupe
privé vous avez par la suite discover
qui émet en avant justement les contenus
de nos partenaires médias de confiance
nous en avons plus de 100 en France qui
sont reconnus justement pour leur
éthique journaliste Spotlight qui est le
nouveau-né de snapchat qui permet de
mettre en avant en fait des vidéos
d'utilisateurs qui sont généralement
humoristiques ou qui présentent on va
dire des scènes quotidiennes de tous les
jours et enfin la map donc la carte qui
met en avant justement des snaps publics
envoyés par notre communauté du monde
entier donc la production de
l'utilisateurs étant notre priorité
l'ensemble des espèces publiques que je
vous ai cités font l'objet d'une
modération humaine exacerbée la
conception elle-même de la plateforme
nous permet on va dire d'assurer une
sorte de rempart structurel contre
touriste de diffusion massive de contenu
illicites ou préjudiciables donc ces
derniers restent donc très rares sur
snapchat et nous n'observons pas pour
répondre à votre question d'évolution en
matière justement de contenu violent où
illicite il n'y a pas plus de contenu
plus massif de ce type de contenu
aujourd'hui qu'il y a plusieurs
semestres plusieurs années comme le
confirme donc nos rapports de
transparence nos conditions générales
d'utilisation et les règles
communautaires de snapchat interdit sur
l'ensemble de la plateforme toutes
diffusion ou partage de contenu illicite
ou préjudiciable celle-ci ont été
rédigées de manière assez claire assez
lisible et facilement accessible pour
l'ensemble de nos membres de notre
communauté à cet effet nous interdisons
explicitement et strictement toute
violence menace ou discours haineux à
l'utilisation de notre plateforme est
interdite explicitement et strictement
pour les groupes terroristes les groupes
extrémistes ou les groupes haineux il
est par ailleurs interdit d'encourager
la violence ou les comportements haineux
ou dangereux visant une personne un
groupe de personnes ou même la propriété
d'une personne juste pour vous définir
ce qu'on entend par menace ou violence
c'est tout contenu donc qui exprime
l'intention de causer un préjudice
physique ou émotionnel grave la violence
ici fait référence à tout contenu qui
tente d'inciter ou de glorifier ou de
représenter la violence humaine la
maltraitance des animaux donc le corps
les scènes graphiques sanglantes ou les
images graphiques donc comme vous le
savez les plateformes ayant une
interdiction de surveillance généralisée
nous accordons comme l'ont indiqué les
présents de plateformes une grande
importance au signalement qu'elle
proviennent d'autorité ou d'utilisateurs
donc nous invitons et nous incitons tout
snapchatteurs qui soient victimes ou
témoins de contenu préjudiciable à le
signifier le plus rapidement possible à
cet effet nous disposons en fait d'un
menu de signalement qui est disponible
sur l'ensemble de la plateforme et qui
présente toutes les catégories illicites
pouvant exister et nous invitons en fait
les snapchats à ajouter plus de
contextes afin de guider justement nos
modérateurs à prendre la bonne décision
une fois le signalement effectué et le
modérateur justement ayant examiné le
signalement l'utilisateur est en signalé
recevra un email directement confirmant
ou infirmant son signalement et avec
l'arrivée justement
du Règlement sur les services numériques
le fameux digital services actes les
utilisateurs auront l'opportunité
justement de faire appel de la décision
de nos modérateurs
en plus donc du signalement de nos
utilisateurs nous avons mis en place
comme les autres plateformes depuis
plusieurs années un programme de
confiance avec nos associations
partenaires donc les trust it flagers
qui peuvent nous signifier en fait tout
contenu illicite ou préjudiciable qui
aurait été signalé par un utilisateur ou
des parents actuellement nos équipes de
modération traitent l'ensemble des
signalements en moins de 24 heures en
parallèle nous avons une équipe qui est
dédiée à la collaboration avec les
forces de l'ordre ils sont dispersés un
peu partout dans le monde afin d'assurer
une rotation 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7 je peux vous confirmer aujourd'hui
que nous avons d'excellentes relations
justement avec l'ensemble des autorités
françaises dans Pharos nous avons mis en
place d'ailleurs une sorte de canal
direct avec Faro afin de traiter le plus
rapidement possible justement l'ensemble
de leurs demandes et aujourd'hui nous
traitons l'ensemble des demandes de
réquisition judiciaire urgentes en moins
de 30 minutes voire plus rapidement
donc snap on essaye de se conformer donc
à l'ensemble des exigences locales et
réglementaires afin d'apporter donc
notre soutien à l'ensemble des forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain et essayer en
fait d'identifier le plus rapidement
possible l'ensemble des délinquants
numériques pour des raisons de
transparence comme les autres
plateformes nous mettons à disposition
du public chaque semaine des rapports de
transparence qui sont ventilés donc par
marcher et partir de délits ou de
catégories illicites ainsi qu'un rapport
de transparence sur notre collaboration
justement avec les forces de l'ordre
selon les pays je vais lire ma fiche
désolé parce que je vous ai mis quelques
indications chiffrées sur les contenus
violents pour le second semestre 2022
mais par exemple au niveau mondial sur
les 827 000 signalement que nous avons
reçu nous avons retiré
229347 contenus et supprimer 138000 13
comptes soit une conversion de 3,6% à
peu près et pour la France ces chiffres
descendent à
54479 signalements pour la même période
avec 10 253 contenu et 6927 comptes
supprimer donc au niveau mondial pour
cette catégorie donc pour les violences
nos équipes ont mis moins de 24 minutes
justement pour traiter l'ensemble des
signalements que nous avons reçu que
cela vienne donc comme je vous l'avais
indiqué d'utilisateur ou d'autorité nous
sommes actuellement en train de préparer
donc notre rapport de transparence pour
le premier semestre de ville 2023 qui
inclut donc la période concernée par
votre commission d'enquête et j'espère
pouvoir vous la communiquer dans les
meilleurs délais donc comme expliqué en
préambule snapchat n'est pas vraiment
conçu pour la diffusion massive de
contenu illicite et violent et donc la
plateforme ne se prête pas vraiment à
l'organisation ou à la diffusion massive
de cette violente militante ou politique
il est par ailleurs important de
préciser comme je l'avais dit au tout
début que nous avons pas de
fonctionnalités live streaming et
autrement dit un utilisateur ne pourra
pas se filmer pendant l'acte et le
diffuser en direct avec l'ensemble de sa
communauté par ailleurs les échanges
privés en fait relevant du secret des
correspondances nous pouvons être saisis
que nous que si pardons nous avons un
signalement de la part
l'utilisateur ou d'une autorité et que
nous traitons par le coup dans les
meilleurs délais pour répondre à une de
vos questions sur justement les
différentes manifestations ayant eu lieu
entre mars et mai 2023 nous n'avons pas
connaissance de signalement ou de
demande de réquisition judiciaire quand
concernant un contenu violent sur
snapchat lié justement à ces
manifestations ni d'augmentation
significative au cours de la période en
revanche je vais en profiter on va dire
de mon cours de ma courte introduction
pour revenir justement sur les émeutes
récentes ayant eu lieu en France qui ont
mobilisé en fait l'ensemble de nos
équipes sur snapchat donc nous avons dès
mardi 27 juin 2023 jour justement du
drame ayant étrené entraîné pardon la
mort du jeune homme de 17 ans crée une
tasse force interne qui réunit nos
équipes de modération nos équipes de
collaboration avec les forces de l'ordre
moi-même et à nos équipes de
d'ingénierie et de communication afin
d'essayer de traiter d'endiguer le plus
rapidement possible justement tous les
contenus nécessite que nous ayons pu
voir donc notre équipe a été en dialogue
constant avec les différents ministères
et autorités locales en répondant donc
rapidement à toute demande ou
préoccupations provenant du gouvernement
ou des autorités françaises donc nous
sommes fiers aujourd'hui comme
l'ensemble des plateformes d'avoir pu
répondre dans des délais très restreints
et dans l'urgence aux trois principales
préoccupations du gouvernement soit la
première c'était retirer le plus
rapidement possible l'ensemble des
contenus signalés la deuxième répondent
le plus rapidement possible aux
réquisitions judiciaire provenant des
autorités françaises et sensibiliser
notre audience sur les différents
phénomènes justement perçus sur le
terrain à ce titre nous avons mis en
place une prioritaire et directe avec
Pharos en traitant donc l'ensemble de
leur demande en seulement quelques
heures voire quelques minutes le
ministère de l'Intérieur et l'ensemble
des autorités françaises nous avons en
parallèle rappelé en fait à nos
partenaires médias les règles
éditoriales qui s'appliquées sur
snapchat afin d'éviter pardon tout
clickbait tout risque de désinformation
massive surtout en cette période de
tension et nous avons promu leur contenu
sur la partie discover afin d'offrir en
fait à nos utilisateurs de snapchat une
information claire vérifiée provenant
vraiment de journalistes plusieurs de
plusieurs de nos créateurs de contenus
ont pris leur caméra snapchat afin de
prendre la parole et de sensibiliser
justement leurs audiences et essayer
d'appeler au calme et comme vous devez
le savoir on nous avons beaucoup entendu
parler de la fonctionnalité carte map de
snapchat nous avons travaillé
conjointement donc avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur et les différentes autorités
afin d'essayer d'endiguer le plus
rapidement possible les différents
dérapages qu'on a pu percevoir sur le
terrain et pour le coup donc l'ensemble
des stories qui étaient publiées sur la
map c'était vraiment des utilisateurs de
snapchat à la fin qui se plaignaient
justement des émeutes et des
conséquences des émeutes donc nous
sommes fiers un peu aujourd'hui d'avoir
pu participer et collaborer justement
entre le privé et le public afin de
protéger nos utilisateurs le plus
rapidement possible
merci beaucoup madame je vais tout de
suite passer la parole la notre
rapporteur oui merci monsieur le
Président merci à vous toutes et tous
pour votre présence au fond ce qui nous
intéresse à travers votre audition c'est
d'un côté ça c'est le côté négatif c'est
comment les plateformes
participent leurs dépens ou pas ça
dépend de l'opinion de chacun
j'allais dire à la viralité
à l'extension en tant que support des
activités violentes pour ça je disais
écouté la négatif et côté positif
comment elle tente de réguler
cette difficulté ce risque et j'aimerais
par conséquent vous entendre sur des
propos peut-être plus d'analyses de
votre part
sur comment vous analysez précisément le
risque que les plateformes dans des
événements clivants des amants
particuliers là nous parlons d'une
période du 16 mars au mois d'avril sur
des rassemblements qui à l'occasion
desquels des violences ont été commises
comment vous vous envisagez votre rôle
l'effet y compris l'effet éventuellement
négatif de mise en scène
parce que ça a échappé à personne que
lorsqu'il y a des rassemblements quels
qu'ils soient ou des événements par des
émeutres récemment il y a une forme de
mise en scène de théâtre de
théâtralisation pardon d'un certain
nombre d'individus ou de groupe
organisés ou pas organisé et qui
profitent des vecteurs que vous
représentez pour accentuer leur audience
voire même le phénomène d'agrégation ou
de mimétisme comment vous analysez cet
élément c'est une question plutôt
d'ordre sociologique si j'ose dire
deuxième question
madame bouchaoua à ma devancé sur la
définition que snapchat donne aux
activités violentes
monsieur Garandeau a répondu sur la
désinformation est-ce que vous avez tous
et toutes la même définition de ce
qu'est une incitation à la violence de
ce qu'est un contenu violent de ce que
sont les violences il y a les
dégradations matérielles il y a les
atteintes aux personnes il y a aussi un
code pénal qui les définit comment vous
situez sur quelle définition est-ce que
vous la partagez est-ce que vous la
mutualisez est-ce que c'est chacun dans
son couloir ça me semble important
d'avoir votre point de vue sur ce sur ce
plan par ailleurs vous n'avez pas tous
donné le nombre de modérateurs
que vous avez recruté vous l'avez fait
meta mais je crois pas l'avoir entendu
me semble-t-il des autres plateformes
donc j'aimerais avoir une vision méta
nous l'avons eu mais peut-être d'aussi
de Tik Tok et de snapchat pour mieux
comprendre aussi la chaîne de décision
que la part algorithmique que la part
modérateur comment tout ceci s'imbrique
et puis comment se se déroule la
décision jusqu'à par exemple la
fermeture du compte
jusque au retrait du contenu et est-ce
que le lien est immédiat avec les forces
de l'ordre le cas échéant avec même les
enquêteurs de la police judiciaire très
concrètement comment la chaîne
fonctionne
et puis ensuite j'aimerais avoir une
précision de votre part nous avons vu de
la part de Tik Tok je vous remercie les
les éléments chiffrés quantitatifs sur
la période du 16 mars au 3 mai
de vidéos retirées de celles dans le
contenu violent était avéré de des
comptes qui ont été supprimés est-ce que
chacun dans votre partie vous pouvez
donner les chiffres de pêche je crois
que snapchat aussi vous l'avez un petit
peu évoqué de préciser sur cette période
parce qu'évidemment pour nous c'est
important d'avoir laissé loop le cas
échéant et puis de montrer la proportion
qu'a pu prendre qu'on peut prendre ces
violences à travers vos plateformes
voilà les premières questions que je
souhaitais vous poser merci beaucoup
monsieur rapporteur donc je vais vous
repasser la parole je ne sais pas qui
souhaite démarrer donc Madame Evrard je
vous en prie juste sur les chiffres nous
on est dans la même cas de figure que
snapchat c'est à dire que nos rapports
se transparence sont émis
semestriellement et donc ça sera publié
fin août plutôt donc ça c'est des
communications de toute manière qui sont
dans le rapport de transparence publique
c'est le lien que Elisa avait mentionné
en préambule donc
vous aurez sur la période au global
effectivement sur cette partie là en
tout cas pour contenu violent contenu
incitant à la violence et voilà cette
partie là juste pour qu'on soit bien
d'accord ça veut dire que on aura les
chiffres sur la période 1er janvier 30
juin 2023 c'est ça ou est-ce que on sera
en mesure d'avoir quelque chose de plus
isolé
trimestre trimestre ce qui veut dire que
on aura d'une part des données sur 1er
janvier 30 mars et puis ensuite et
ensuite 1er avril 30 juin tout à fait
très bien
sur le nombre de modérateurs on l'a dit
donc ça on a une équipe de 40 000 et
15000 modérateurs concernant la chaîne
de décision vu le volume que nous avons
à traiter vous comprenez qu'en fait on
travaille de Père et avec l'intelligence
artificielle et avec la partie
modérateur humain c'est tout à fait l'un
et l'autre sont tout à fait
complémentaires
sur des contenus violents comme c'est
assez graphique on a des très bons
résultats c'est ce qu'on vous disait sur
les taux qui étaient avancés de
détection proactive en tout cas par nos
machines étant donné que c'est des
choses qui sur lesquelles la machine a
pu s'entraîner avec quand il y a du sang
voilà ce genre de choses c'est assez
graphique donc c'est entre guillemets
plus simple pour la machine à détecter
donc on a des très bons résultats
toutefois dans il y a aussi un contexte
à prendre en considération une culture à
prendre en considération donc il peut y
avoir effectivement une revue manuelle
additionnelle par fait par un homme
modérateur
là-dessus c'est le même système que ce
qu'a expliqué Tik Tok avec des réponses
graduées qui vont se mettre en place au
regard de la violation qui aura été
constatée
vous pouvez bien évidemment faire
recours enfin recours sur la décision
qui sera si vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec la décision que meta a pris sur un
pour retirer un contenu par exemple ça
sera revu toujours par un modérateur
différent du premier pour éviter les
éventuels biais que le premier
modérateur aurait pu avoir si vous
n'êtes toujours pas d'accord avec le
deuxième modérateur vous avez encore un
recours qui est possible et là soit en
fait ce sont les mêmes décisions qui
sont pris par le modérateur 1 et 2 dans
ces cas-là on revoit mais par un
seigneur et voilà soit il y a une
différence et le Seigneur va trancher
aussi pour donner une décision finale
toutefois
si vous n'êtes toujours pas satisfait on
a mis en place un comité de surveillance
qui est indépendant de métal qui
regroupe une vingtaine maintenant doit
être 25
indépendants experts au niveau global
pas uniquement français mais il y aura
toutes les nationalités qui sont qui
sont représentées qui va pouvoir en tout
cas revoir la décision qui aura été
prise et faire éventuellement aussi des
recommandations suite à nos politiques
pour faire évoluer soit la définition de
ce qu'on entend par un contenu violent
par exemple ou pas donc vous avez aussi
tout le travail qui est fait pour faire
évoluer nos politiques si on a vu que
par une décision on a pris une mauvaise
décision
concernant justement la définition elles
sont publiques en fait là aussi sur le
rapport de transparence dans la
catégorisation vous avez toute la
définition qui est donnée sur chaque
violation je crois que c'était
oui peut-être juste pour compléter
effectivement le propos de Béatrice
notamment sur la question qui concernait
les définitions donc effectivement les
nôtres sont publiques je pense que c'est
le cas de toutes les plateformes je
voulais juste relever un point qui est
intéressant qui est aussi que il existe
des forums bien sûr au cours desquels on
peut échanger sur ces sujets et
notamment je pense que le thème sur
lequel la coopération entre les
plateformes est sans doute la plus
avancée c'est sans doute la lutte contre
le terrorisme donc il y a vous
connaissez peut-être le forum internet
mondial de la lutte contre le terrorisme
give City qui a permis de développer
notamment quelques outils et
technologiques communes et donc de
pouvoir se partager des contenus afin de
les retirer à l'échelle sur toutes les
plateformes nous on a open sourcée
également un outil qui est utile dans le
travail de modération chez méta mais
également chez d'autres plateformes
puisque donc il est mis à disposition
l'idée étant qu'il soit utilisé
notamment par les plus petites
plateformes qui n'ont pas forcément les
mêmes ressources que nous c'est l'outil
HMA donc le nom très long c'est
actionner mais ça permet effectivement
d'attribuer une étiquette en fait à un
contenu numérique pour pouvoir en
empêcher le la publication à échelle sur
sa propre plateforme et donc de pouvoir
copier ce modèle sur d'autres
plateformes donc il y a effectivement
des définitions et des coopérations
sur tout ce qui concerne les fausses
informations d'un système un peu
similaire à celui de que Tik Tok a
également à travers la coopération avec
des organismes externes de vérification
de l'information
voilà peut-être également je voulais
rajouter un élément sur sur l'analyse
aussi que vous mentionnez donc comme on
peut analyser l'utilisation qui peut
être faite des plateformes par ce type
de groupe
nous comme on vous le disait notre
priorité absolue c'est évidemment de
faire en sorte que les contenus les plus
violents soient retirés soit en fonction
de la sensibilité de chacun marquer
comme sensible donc notre priorité c'est
de retirer le plus rapidement possible
ces contenus c'est pourquoi nous-mêmes
on n'a pas nécessairement d'analyse on
va dire de de commencer groupe peuvent
utiliser tel ou tel format en revanche
qu'on privilégie beaucoup chez méta et
de plus en plus c'est la coopération
avec le monde de la recherche ces
dernières années on a pu mettre à
disposition des chercheurs plus de 1000
jeux de données et on a annoncé la
semaine dernière la création d'une
nouvelle bibliothèque de contenu public
qui va permettre aux chercheurs au monde
académique de pouvoir accéder à tous les
contenus publics de page de profil de
groupes ou d'événements sur sur nos
plateformes et donc ça te permettra
peut-être l'émergence on espère en tout
cas d'études comparer pays par pays
c'était aussi une question que vous
aviez mentionné dans le questionnaire et
ce qu'il existe une spécificité
française dans la mesure où nos outils
sont les mêmes dans tous les pays nous
aussi on s'interroge en fait sur voilà
sur sur cette spécificité possible
peut-être que c'est
dans l'autre sens qu'il faut se poser la
question dans la mesure où voilà ces
outils existent également en Italie en
Allemagne en Angleterre et on observe
pas nécessairement les mêmes phénomènes
merci beaucoup monsieur carreau merci
monsieur le Président et monsieur le
rapporteur donc je vais essayer de
répondre là aussi à toute la série de
questions alors parler de la sociologie
et aussi de la manière dont les
utilisateurs utilisent l'outil et dans
la manière dont il peut aussi détourner
essayer de détourner l'outil
il faut c'est intéressant de rappeler
que pour avoir du succès sur sur
l'application sur Tik Tok donc il faut
faire des des vidéos et de fabriquer une
vidéo qui va avoir du succès ça
nécessite d'avoir un talent et ça je
pourrais tout un chacun peut en faire
l'expérience donc ça met aussi une
barrière à l'entrée c'est autant c'est
très facile de faire un tweet ou de
mettre une photo dans la nature autant
de faire une vidéo qui va avoir une
un impact c'est déjà voilà ça ça conduit
assez à faire le tri déjà dans les dans
les personnes qui peuvent utiliser cette
plateforme et qui peuvent avoir du
succès ensuite il faut savoir que plus
une vidéo est virale sur Tik Tok plus
elle va être modérée c'est à dire que la
vidéo elle est l'algorithme va la tester
sur un certain nombre de personnes voir
comment les gens réagissent et puis si
les gens réagissent bien s'il commente
ils partagent la vidéo va tester sur un
cercle de personnes plus important et
ainsi de suite jusqu'à avoir
éventuellement une vie une visibilité
mondiale et à chaque fois qu'il y a ce
cycle d'élargissement de l'audience il y
a un tour de modération qui est fait
donc ça c'est ça permet de détecter si
par hasard dans un premier tour de
modération on n'a pas détecté qu'il y
avait une des informations qui avait une
violence qui était peut-être un peu
cachée logiquement le deuxième tour le
troisième tour vont permettre de de
révéler cette dangerosité et donc de
supprimer la vidéo donc ça c'est ça
c'est important ce que comme ils l'ont
dit mes collègues la violence
le côté gore le côté graphique c'est
quelque chose que les algorithmes
détecte très bien une simple goutte de
sang peut à l'écran conduire à cette
détection
et donc les taux de retrait
proactifs la durée de retrait aussi donc
le fait que ce soit retiré dans l'heure
ou en tout cas avant 24 heures le fait
que ça puisse être aussi retiré avant la
première vue toutes ces statistiques sur
la violence sont excellentes alors c'est
pas pour dire que tout est parfait sur
la plateforme donc je vous dirais à
contrario par exemple le
cyber-harcèlement est beaucoup plus vite
difficile à détecter parce que ça
nécessite une prise en compte du
contexte et que parfois on a des vidéos
qui sont des vidéos de cyber-harcèlement
alors qu'en fait elles sont totalement
anodines les mots même employés sont pas
du tout des mots choquants mais quand on
connaît le contexte on peut se dire bah
oui en fait c'est de la séduire
harcèlement donc en matière de violence
c'est voilà on dirait que les
performances sont plutôt très bonnes
ensuite les la manière dont la
modération se fait donc il y a
effectivement ce premier tour
algorithmique puis l'intervention du
facteur humain s'il y a une nécessité de
d'avoir un regard humain par exemple
quand vous voyez une croix gammée sur
une vidéo
ça peut être une vidéo néonazi ça peut
être aussi une vidéo du Mémorial de la
Shoah qui va faire de la pédagogie pour
justement lutter contre le nazisme donc
c'est ça ça nécessite effectivement un
regard humain
et c'est pour ça qu'on a donc 600
modérateurs en langue française et
évidemment des dizaines de milliers dans
les autres langues la chaîne avec les
autorités elle s'exerce à différents
niveaux soit là on parle de retrait de
contenu donc c'est avant tout Pharos qui
est l'organisme référencé sur lequel il
y a une procédure extrêmement rapide de
communication et de traitement quasi
immédiat de des demandes et ensuite ça
peut être aussi des réquétitions de la
police nationale ou de la gendarmerie là
aussi c'est un service spécialisé dans
notre équipe très sainte qui gère ses
demandes avec une procédure d'urgence et
une procédure je dirais plus classique
mais donc dès que la procédure d'urgence
est utilisée la réponse normalement a
lieu dans le dans l'heure qui vient
pour les émeutes alors pas pas au
printemps mais plus récemment fin juin
on a aussi constitué une cellule de
crise on l'a fait on le fait aussi pour
toutes les élections nationales mais on
l'a fait pour les émeutes puisque
c'était on voyait bien qu'il y avait une
nécessité d'être encore plus présent et
donc là on a mis en place des équipes
surnumerair pour pouvoir être encore
plus actif et plus efficace et donc ça a
permis de traiter là aussi les demandes
de Pharos elle n'est pas très nombreuses
on a eu 10 demandes sur toute la semaine
mais elles ont été traités très
rapidement sur les règles communautaires
alors c'est vrai qu'on a des règles je
pense qui sont chaque plateforme assez
nuance aussi parce que chaque plateforme
a son positionnement son public
donc évidemment on applique le DSA qui
est en train d'arriver la loi pénale
dans chaque pays et donc évidemment la
loi pénale française et puis on a des
règles propres par exemple chez Tik Tok
la pornographie est interdite mais aussi
la nudité puisque on a une partie
utilisateurs qui sont mineurs et donc on
considère tout ce qui est nudité est
interdit on est très vigilant là-dessus
et puis on s'inspire de tous les textes
qu'on peut trouver
digne d'intérêt notamment par exemple
les textes des Nations Unies sur le
respect des droits de l'homme avec
universelle des droits de l'homme ou la
Charte des Droits de l'Enfant aussi donc
tous ces textes ont inspiré nos règles
communautaires et on a aussi comme ça a
été dit par mes collègues un conseil
consultatif européen qui d'ailleurs
intègre la directrice générale de i en
France juste une Atlan et donc ce
conseil consultatif ce conseil
constitutif est consulté sur les règles
communautaires et va pouvoir aussi
apporter un conseil précieux pour les
faire évoluer c'est c'est réglé évolué
en permanence récemment il y a une loi
qui a été votée sur le métier des
influenceurs vous le savez puisque vous
l'avez voté et donc évidemment on
modifie aussitôt nos règles pour pour
prendre en compte cette loi
voilà et juste peut-être par rapport au
mimétisme ça c'est un sujet sur lesquels
on a beaucoup travaillé notamment sur
les jeunes publics notamment parce qu'on
avait été assez sollicité sur tout ce
qui était défi dangereux ou canular
dangereux donnant l'impression d'un défi
dangereux même si t'es un canular ça
peut
encourager des jeunes à faire la même
chose et donc c'est des travaux de
recherche qui ont vocation à se
poursuivre avec le milieu académique
y compris en utilisant des API qu'on est
en train de mettre à disposition des
chercheurs là aussi dans le cadre du DSA
et nous ça nous a permis déjà de mettre
en place des politiques de communication
des opérations de sensibilisation qui
sont destinées
à permettre à nos utilisateurs de
prendre conscience aussi de prendre du
recul par rapport à ce qu'il voit par
rapport à ce qu'ils font de se poser des
questions
donc on l'a fait dans différents
domaines d'activités on n'a pas on n'a
pas fait forcément pour des émeuts de
violentes parce que c'est encore très
récent mais on peut le on peut le faire
aussi dans ce dans ce domaine
je vous remercie d'être passé la parole
aussi à Madame bouchaoua
je sais qu'il ne reste pas beaucoup de
minutes donc je vais essayer de répondre
à l'ensemble des questions qui ont été
posées sur la lutte contre la
prolifération justement des contenus
violents posés par monsieur le
rapporteur
côté snapchat je pense qu'il en fait
tout réside dans la conception de la
plateforme à titre d'exemple c'est
vraiment la lutte contre la viralité
afin justement d'éviter qu'un contenu
soit partagé le plus rapidement possible
de même la fonctionnalité live par
exemple mais de toute manière on a le
DSA qui arrive où chaque plateforme va
devoir prendre ses responsabilités
justement et répondre dans les meilleurs
délais à toutes les signalements qui ont
été émis soit par des autorités soit
justement par des utilisateurs sur
comment tenter d'endiguer les contenus
je pense que c'était la deuxième
question de monsieur le rapporteur je
pense qu'il faut surtout renforcer comme
je l'avais dit au tout début la
collaboration entre le privé et le
public à ce titre je crois que c'était
méta qu'il avait dit au tout début nous
sommes tous membres du GCP du groupe de
contact permanent justement sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme et les extrêmes
violences
ou justement avec l'ensemble de nos
interlocuteurs on a le droit d'avoir des
remontées de terrain justement afin
d'être justement le plus réactif
possible et essayer par la suite de
transmettre les différents messages à
nos équipes de modération sur la
théâtralisation et le bimétisme je pense
qu'il faut faire également beaucoup de
pédagogie je rejoins l'ensemble des
dires qui ont été indiqués par mes
collègues mais surtout je pense qu'il
faut et c'est ce qu'on avait dit ces
derniers jours que l'anonymat enfin
rappeler que l'anonymat sur Internet
n'existe pas c'est à dire que quoi vous
fassiez sur Internet on pourra vous
retrouver il suffit que la plateforme
reçoit une réquisition judiciaire de la
part des autorités justement locales et
ben la plateforme va répondre il y a le
DSA qui arrive à nouveau il y a
justement aussi evidence qui arrive et
on pourra vous retrouver rapidement donc
tout n'est pas un puni
sur la définition de la modération côté
snapchat les règles générales
d'utilisation reflètent en fait les lois
locales nous avons donc les conditions
générales d'utilisation qui sont
divisées en deux catégories on a celles
qui sont applicables pour les États-Unis
qui rappelle justement les règles des
États-Unis et nous en avons d'autres qui
rappellent justement les règles
concernant l'Union européenne qui
reflète justement le code pénal français
et les autres marchés de l'Union
européenne sur le nombre de modérateurs
nous en avons plus plusieurs milliers
chez snapchat et je pourrais vous les
communiquer justement lors de ma
contribution écrite je l'espère et je
pense qu'il est également important de
rappeler que il y a l'interdiction de
surveiller en généraliser néanmoins
quand nous sommes face à des cas
justement d'extrême violence je peux
citer par exemple que ce soit le
terrorisme ou par exemple la
pédocrinalité nous sommes assez
proactifs en la matière et pour vous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne c'est un
peu comme pour les autres plateformes
mais pour ces cas précis on envoie
directement enfin signal directement au
nake me aux États-Unis qui va par la
suite transmettre au marché concerné
concernant le terrorisme c'est
directement le siège dentaire Paul à
Washington DC qui va être en contact du
coup avec la plateforme on va envoyer
une sorte de hache donc la vidéo
concernée Interpol Washington DC va le
transmettre à Interpol Europe et de le
transmettre directement par exemple pour
la France au département de justice par
la suite on va se partager donc
l'ensemble des haches pour détecter le
plus rapidement possible donc les
différentes vidéos concernées sur la
modération à nouveau je tiens à préciser
qu'il est également important à chaque
fois assurer une sorte d'intervention
humaine comme l'a expliqué Tik Tok quand
il y a une croix gammée ça peut être
justement à titre vraiment néo-nazi et
là c'est très grave il faut le retirer
le plus rapidement possible ou à des
fins justement d'éducation donc c'est
pour cela que nous côté snapchat on ne
se base pas que sur la modération
algorithmique mais à chaque bout de
chaîne en fait nous avons un utilisateur
qui va pouvoir analyser le contenu selon
justement la catégorie qui est concernée
à titre d'exemple quand il s'agit de
désinformation
c'est essentiellement de l'intervention
humaine pour bien analyser le contexte
et savoir la spécificité du marché par
exemple on a parlé des élections
présidentielles à ce titre nous
organisons généralement des points
hebdomadaires avec nos équipes pour voir
justement les différentes remontées de
terrain voir quand il y a des débats
présidentiels avec les différents
candidats et justement faire remonter
tout ce qu'on peut percevoir ou entendre
sur le terrain
très bien bah écoutez merci beaucoup
donc soyez mesdames et messieurs
vivement remercier pour la qualité de
cet échange donc comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous le dire nous nous
restons en attente de la contribution
écrite en tout cas vos prises de parole
cet après-midi nous ont permis de
d'éclairer cette cette question et comme
j'avais eu l'occasion de le dire pour
pour Twitter ils nous ont fourni une une
réponse écrite puisque il ne pouvait pas
être présent
parmi nous au même enfin l'horaire en
question
j'indique mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre quelques minutes la séance
pour permettre l'arrivée de Monsieur le
Préfet Delpech et donc